voilà monsieur le président longeau mes
chers collègues madame la présidente
donc nous continuons notre cycle
d'auditions relative au projet de
rapprochement entre veolia et suez par
votre audition madame dominique
senequier vous qui êtes présidente du
fonds d'investissement ares dian voilà
si certains d'entre nous ne
connaissaient pas ce fond je crois que
depuis quelques jours nous connaissons
parfaitement madame la présidence par
contraste avec le fracas j'allais dire
de la bataille médiatique que se livrent
depuis plusieurs mois les principaux
protagonistes mme protagonistes pardon
du feuilleton économique veolia suez
vous êtes resté jusqu'à présent plutôt
en dehors du feu des projecteurs et des
tribunes de presse nous sommes donc
heureux de vous recevoir pour échanger
au sujet de vos projets pour suez comme
nous l'avons fait je voulais indiqué il
ya quelques instants avec le fond
meridian et monsieur des eaux veolia qui
a annoncé l'été dernier son intention
d'acquérir son principal concurrent suez
n'a cessé de présenter son projet de
fusion comme le seul à même de garantir
que suez reste français face aux risques
de la concurrence chinoise et
d'éventuelles cessions à des acteurs
étrangers dans les dernières
communications de monsieur frérot du
groupe veolia il oppose souvent un
projet industriel français à un projet
financier américain depuis plusieurs
mois le nerf de la guerre si vous me
permettez l'expression est donc celui
d'éventuelles offres ou d'éventuels
autres projets alternatifs à celle de
présenter par veolia est il possible
d'imaginer un autre avenir pour suez qui
ne passe pas par une fusion avec veolia
nous prise de contrôle étrangère ou une
vente à la découpe à meridiam ou à
d'autres concurrents
c'est en réponse à cette question car
dian est entrée par deux fois dans le
dossier veolia suez depuis l'été d'abord
en septembre dernier où le fonds
d'investissement que vous présidez a
fait connaître son intérêt pour les 29
9% de suez visées par l'offre d'achat de
veolia auprès de j vous avez finalement
renoncé à déposer une offre concurrente
expliquant vouloir donner du temps aux
discussions
ensuite il y à un mois vous avez finale
mon déposé avec le fonds américain jay-z
une lettre d'intention portant un projet
alternatif pour le groupe suez projet
alternatif
est ce un projet industriel est ce un
projet financier vous nous le dira et
pourriez vous tout d'abord nous éclairer
sur les réseaux qui ne vous ont pas
permis à l'automne de déposer l'offre
que vous avez des finalement déposé en
janvier elles sont raison de l'absence
d'un partenaire tel que jaypee de
difficultés à mobiliser les financements
nécessaires
tout simplement par manque de temps ce
calendrier nous interroge sur le cadre
dans lequel s'est déroulé l'examen par
angie de l'offre de veolia en effet
l'ultimatum qui a été déposés par veolia
dans un délai d'un mois nous sommes le
pas avoir permis l'émergence justement
d'offres alternatives qui était pourtant
à portée de main résultant en un blocage
de plusieurs semaines je vais dire
maintenant de plusieurs mois et en un
durcissement des positions respectifs
un délai minimal serait-il souhaitable
dans ce type de situation en outre
l'état aurait-il pu jouer un plus grand
rôle pour faire jouer la concurrence et
accompagner des offres alternatives
telles que celle d'argent je pense que
vous attendiez ce que je vous pose cette
question je crois que vous aviez
d'ailleurs informé le ministre de
l'économie que vous travaillez sur une
proposition
comment est-ce que cette proposition a
été reçue estimez-vous qu'un soutien de
la caisse des dépôts ou de bpi france
aurait pu permettre de constituer plus
rapidement une offre alternative à celle
de veolia
j'en reviens aux événements les plus
récents alors que beaucoup présenter
l'offre d'ares dian hadji à hippies
comme une opportunité de sortie par le
haut du blocage dans lequel se trouvait
à veolia et suez loupé a lancé hier
lundi dernier semble refermé la porte à
tout dialogue ait abandonné tout
semblant d'amis qualité pourtant sur
lesquels les uns et les autres s'étaient
engagés quelles sont les conséquences
concrètes du lancement anticipé de l'opé
assure votre offre de rachat de
participations au capital de suez
pourriez vous nous indiquer si votre
projet impliquait lui aussi le pea sur
une partie du capital du groupe ou
s'agissait-il uniquement de racheter les
29 9% anciennement détenu par angie
ensuite les négociations amorcées avec
véolia avait-elle abouti était telle au
bout voilà en quelques lignes
madame les questions que je voulais vous
poser avant de
passé la parole à mon collègue le
président loger merci madame la
présidente prix madame madame la
présidente mais mes chers collègues nous
poursuivons nos auditions de ce jour en
entendant à présent la présidente de la
société ardian madame dominique
senequier dans le cadre des travaux du
comité de suivi
veolia suez madame la présidente la
presse vous présente comme le chevalier
blanc de suez
vous présidez hard y en une société
française d'investissement société
privée qui gère plus de 110 milliards de
dollars d'actifs qui fait de votre
groupe un des grands acteurs mondiaux du
non-coté vous annoncer le 17 janvier
avoir noué une alliance avec le fonds
américain jp d'avoir infrastructure
partners est remis à suez une lettre
d'intention pour un projet alternatif à
celui de veolia en précisant qu'il
s'agit d'une solution amicale et non
concurrentes
voilà pour le contexte votre société
créée en 2005 un pôle infrastructure
mais il ne s'agit pas du coeur de vos
actifs nous expériences passées d'un
secteur de l'eau n'ont pas toujours été
des succès comme en témoigne votre
investissement dans la saur passer à
côté de la faillite en 2013 avec une
dette de près de 2 milliards d'euros
comprendrez que les parlementaires que
nous sommes nourris ce juste titre des
inquiétudes quant à l'intérêt que vous
manifestez à l'activité eau de suez
cela nous conduit dans un premier à un
premier thème de questions quels projets
industriels portez-vous aux côtés de
suez
quel est votre horizon d'investissement
dans un secteur où la temporalité se
mesurant décennies pourquoi vous être
allié avec j p un fonds d'investissement
américain à la recherche de taux de
rentabilité élevé
ce qui n'est pas du le cas du marché de
l'eau en france
l'eau n'est pas un actif comme les
autres elle est essentielle pour nos
territoires est essentielle pour nos
collectivités
la qualité et le prix de l'eau est un
enjeu majeur
pour les élus locaux leur bilan est
évaluée à l'aune de l'évolution de la
fiscalité des services rendus à la
population
mais s'appuie également sur la
modération et c'est important de
modération de la hausse des prix de
l'eau les maires et présidents
d'intercommunalités ils sont très
sensibles et la bataille de l'eau qui a
cours actuellement les inquiète à bon
droit
quelle est votre approche en tant
qu'investisseur comment comptez-vous
rentabiliser cet investissement 1 quels
engagements prenez vous pour l'emploi la
qualité de service et le prix de l'eau
payé par le consommateur aux finalités
autres fonds a manifesté un intérêt dans
cette opération en septembre dernier
pour finalement ne pas donner suite
l essai et veolia acheter les parts que
détenait jmj dans suez le 17 janvier
vous avez remis une lettre d'intention à
suez dans le cadre d'une proposition
amicale ce sont vos termes
celle ci n'a pas été rendu public en
quoi concile consiste-t-elle et comment
s'articulent tél avec l'offre de veolia
comment avez vous travaillé qu suez
quels sont vos objectifs sur ce dossier
quelle lecture faites vous des dernières
actualités sur ce dossier à savoir
l'offre publique d'acquisition de veolia
d'acheter la totalité du capital de suez
à 18 euros par titre et la décision du
tribunal de commerce de nanterre qu'elle
vous paraît être le calendrier à venir
nos inquiétudes concernent également les
coûteuses investissements nécessaires
dans les infrastructures afin d'assurer
la continuité et l'amélioration de la
qualité de l'eau tout en garantissant un
réseau encore plus performant réseau
avec moins de fuites des contrôles
performant en temps réel de la captation
à la distribution un opérateur financier
tels que vous alliez à un fonds
américain sera-t-il en mesure de
garantir l'accroissement de la qualité
de la distribution et de
l'assainissement de l'eau notre
commission d'aménagement du territoire
et du développement durable est très
attaché à ce que l'école française de
l'eau continue à prospérer et conserve
son
expertise et son savoir faire au service
de des territoires au service des élus
en un mot au service de nos concitoyens
la souveraineté économique a fait un
retour en force dans le discours
politique à la lumière de la crise
sanitaire ne voulons pas que le savoir
faire français dans le secteur de l'eau
soit vendue à la découpe d'ici plusieurs
années un des groupes étrangers
nous souhaitons vous entendre sur ses
nombreux sujets connaître votre
sentiment quant aux craintes qui
s'expriment et dont nous sommes les
relais ce sujet comporte de nombreuses
zones dont sur lesquels j'espère madame
la présidente que vous ferez toute la
lumière
je vous sais de la parole merci vous
écoutons madame la présidente madame la
présidente monsieur le président
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs
merci de votre écoute de votre
disponibilité en 2005 comme je vous le
disais j'ai eu l'honneur d'être
auditionné comme rapporteur sur le sujet
de la privatisation d'edf
lorsque gérard larcher avait créé une
commission économie à cette occasion
gardians s'appelait encore axa private
equity depuis nous sommes devenus ardien
une société de gestion indépendante
internationale est majoritairement
détenue par ses 750 collaborateurs
plus de la moitié travaille à paris
haarde y en est comparable aux autres
sociétés de gestion françaises
que son amundi bnp paribas asset
management ou encore axa investment
managers et à ce titre hard y en ait
soumis à toutes les réglementations et
aux autorités de supervision nationales
comme la mf en france la hesse ici aux
etats unis la m6 et à londres et et
quelques autres puisque nous sommes dans
15 bureaux
nous nous sommes développés depuis 24
ans dans de très nombreux secteurs et
notamment celui des infrastructures nous
gérons effectivement aujourd'hui comme
vous l'avez dit monsieur le président
près de 90 milliards d'euros ce qui nous
fait de nous le premier de très loin
acteur européen et le 5e mondial après
quatre américains nous gérons ces
capitaux qui sont confiés par des
investisseurs qui sont des fonds de
retraite plus tôt valdir étranger
puisqu'il ya pas beaucoup de fonds de
pension en france qui investissent à
très long terme des sociétés d'assurance
des fonds souverains et si mon activité
en fait tu m'amènes pas mal voyagé à
ouvrir de nouveaux bureaux dans le dans
le monde
je suis très fier de dire que notre
société française de nos dirigeants sont
français et chaque fois que nos
entreprises réussissent à l'étranger
je me réjouis qu'elle porte aux
l'excellence du savoir-faire français
nous sommes je dirais les champions
d'accompagner le développement
d'entreprises françaises je suis très
heureuse effectivement que hard y en ait
contribué à l'émergence de ces champions
européens et particuliers mondiaux
d'origine française
je veux citer deux ou trois exemples on
à quercia qui était le leader
international de la sécurité alimentaire
cls qui est spécialisée dans le
développement de soutien dédié à l'étude
de la protection de notre planète et à
la gestion durable de ces ressources ou
encore serré lia très intéressante
société magnifique à planter dans le
nord de la france est aussi mondial
leader européen de la fabrication de
pâte à tarte et de produits boulangers
pour cela nous investissent
massivement dans les entreprises que
nous accompagnons dans leurs
développements dans le renforcement de
leur unité de production dans
l'identification d'opportunités et de
relais de croissance nous fait nous nous
appuyons évidemment sur tous nos réseaux
de partenaires publics et privés des
collectivités locales lorsqu'il ya lieu
deux sociétés d'acteurs industriels et
on va le dire aussi beaucoup
d'entrepreneurs de très grande qualité
notre accompagnement de long terme se
traduit par des créations d'emplois
créés vingt-six mille emplois en
l'espace de quelques années et par
quelque chose que nous nous nous avons
été les pionniers c'est à dire le
partage de la valeur créée avec les
salariés des entreprises que nous
accompagnons en 2008
comme je viens de vous le dire nous
avons été le premiers acteurs du capital
investissement à mettre au coeur de
notre activité le partage de cette
valeur créée avec les salariés et nous
avons été aussi l'un des premiers
acteurs à insérer dans nos critères
d'investissement et on est sur ce sujet
je dirais un des leaders mondiaux toutes
les mesures et amélioration des impacts
environnementaux sociétaux et de
gouvernance pour nos entreprises cette
responsabilité sociétale elle est au
coeur des valeurs gardians et nous
l'appliquons également à notre niveau
puisqu'à ce jour plus de 70 % de nos
équipes sont actionnaires d'argan depuis
comme vous l'avez dit monsieur le
président nous sommes actifs dans le
domaine des infrastructures dans lequel
nous avons ces dernières années
considérablement renforcer notre
expertise sous l'impulsion de mathias
burghardt qui m'accompagnent aujourd'hui
nous travaillons aux côtés d'industriels
aux côtés de collectivités territoriales
en france en europe
nous travaillons au côté d'investisseurs
dans les domaines des infrastructures
environnementales infrastructures de
télécommunications d
pour la téléphonie mobile à la fibre
optique des infrastructures de
transports telles que des aéroports des
lignes à grande vitesse et des
autoroutes
quelques exemples concrets puisqu'on
n'est pas effectivement très connu vinci
a choisi hard y en pour développer la
ligne à grande vitesse tours bordeaux un
des plus grand projet européen
d'infrastructures de l'ordre de huit
milliards d'euros
nous avons été aussi choisi par edf dans
un partenariat à 50-50 pour reprendre
géosel deuxième site européen de
stockage d'hydrocarbures au groupe total
site éminemment stratégique pour la
france
vous vous en souvenez il ya quelques
mois les départements d'ile-de-france
avec malheureusement notre ami patrick
devedjian ont également fait appel à
nous pour proposer au gouvernement une
solution innovante dans le cadre de la
privatisation des aéroports de paris
ils nous ont choisis en particulier pour
notre ancrage territorial pour notre
expérience puisque on est actionnaire
d'aéroports dans toute l'italie et notre
capacité d'investissement et notre
expertise industrielle volant alors pour
répondre plus précisément aux sujets que
vous avez soulevé
je vous remercie effectivement de nous
entendre aujourd'hui pour que nous
puissions vous expliquer la raison de
notre démarche et vous convaincre de
notre ambition pour suez
dans ce dossier nous distinguons deux
phases la première débute en septembre
lorsque la direction de suez nous
contacter en vue de proposer une offre
alternative sur l'ensemble du groupe
suez
nous avons bien sûr répondu présent
car suez est une très belle entreprise
l'un de nos rares leaders mondiaux dans
ce domaine avec une vision et un plan
stratégique
solide pertinents qui s'appelle suez
cette première phase s'est achevée le 4
octobre 2020 lorsque nous décidons de ne
pas donner suite à notre lettre
d'intention face à les précipitations d'
angie précipitations vous le savez a
cédé un bloc de 29 9% de la société suez
à veolia
la seconde phase intervient dès le 17
janvier dernier nous avons remis avec
nos partenaires de jaypee une lettre
d'intention au conseil d'administration
de suez en prenant acte du fait que
veolia détenait désormais une part
significative du capital de son
concurrent
le contenu de cette lettre indique
gardians et jeep y sont prêts à
accompagner suez dans le cadre d'une
solution négociée entre suez et veolia
avec jaypee nous défendons de
convictions très simple
ma première conviction c'est qu'il n'y a
pas de meilleur projet pour suez que
celui que l'entreprise s'est choisi pour
elle même tout le monde s'accorde pour
dire que c'est une très belle entreprise
donc nous pensons qu'elle a les moyens
de se développer par elle même
n'oublions pas que c'est une entreprise
dont la capitalisation est de l'ordre de
11 milliards d'euros ce qui déjà en
france est une très belle capitalisation
ma seconde conviction c'est qu'il y à
une voie possible pour un veolia et un
suez
puissant tous deux au mouvement
et tous deux mieux armé pour investir et
se développer en recentrant chacune de
ces deux entreprises sur leurs points
forts et avec des stratégies
industrielles forte et cohérente
la france pourrait compter sur deux
champions mon dieu mon dieu oh pardon
moteur d'innovation et créateurs
d'emplois
et bien sûr vos collectivités pourraient
bénéficier ainsi et continuer à
bénéficier d'une concurrence réelle
synonyme de progrès technologique de
prix plus compétitifs et d'un engagement
environnemental redoublé nous sommes
donc toujours prêt à accompagner une
solution négociée qui permettrait à suez
de continuer de mettre son plan en
oeuvre dans une version adaptée bien
évidemment à la nouvelle donne nous
n'avons pas toutes les réponses
aujourd'hui mais nous sommes
rigoureusement attaché un certain nombre
de points essentiels à la solution à la
construction d'une solution efficace
premièrement le maintien d'une identité
d'une implantation française forte une
cohérence industrielle effectivement
autour de l'eau un périmètre qui doit
être suffisamment préserver pour être
viable l'intégrité de la recherche de
suez et bien sûr l'accord des parties
prenantes
permettez moi à ce stade à présent de
donner la parole à mathias burghardt
pour vous exposer comment nous avons
aujourd'hui la conviction plus en détail
de pouvoir contribuer à cette solution
merci merci dominique madame la
présidente monsieur le président madame
dessinatrice messieurs les sénateurs
je suis mathias burghardt et je dirige à
ardillon infrastructures que j'ai créée
en 2005 au sein de notre ancien ancienne
maison mère axa depuis 2010 nous avons
investi plus de 16 milliards d'euros
dans des infrastructures de transport
d'énergie de télécommunications et de
services environnementaux
notre conviction est que les
infrastructures ont beaucoup changé
elle nécessite aujourd'hui la mise en
oeuvre de partenariats nouveaux pour se
renforcer
se développer et surtout pour apporter
des solutions concrètes aux
grands défis et aux transitions que nous
vivons économique technologique
démographique et bien sûr écologique
c'est pourquoi nous avons acquis une
expertise industrielle de grande qualité
combinée à une expertise financière la
solution que nous proposons pour siège
avec notre partenaire jp s'appuie sur
quelques lignes de force que nous avons
définies avec le management et le
conseil d'administration de suez et que
nous avons partagé avec l'intersyndicale
la solution que nous pourrons se retient
donc cinq points pour cette solution
d'abord maintenir l'indépendance de suez
et accélérer son développement comme
leader mondial
hal gill est dédiée aux services à
l'environnement avec des ressources en
capital significatives une stratégie
d'investissement sur le long terme
le deuxième s'est renforcé la force la
france pardon dans notre projet suez
france est confirmé en tant qu'entité
central du groupe de dimension
internationale avec les centres de
décision et de recherche reste en france
pour le reste du monde c'est une
question stratégique c'est aussi un
enjeu de culture d'entreprise renforcer
l'actionnariat salarié et les dialogues
avec les parties prenantes nous
souhaitons construire notre projet avec
les collaborateurs de suez notre projet
garantit un capitaine majorité française
et un actionnariat salarié
significativement renforcée assurer les
meilleures politiques sociales également
c'est déjà le cas pour suez et nous
entendons les préserver permettre à suez
de se fixer aussi les plus hauts
standards en matière de transition
écologique pour définir une entreprise
impact positif sur 100% de ses activités
en trois mots la solution que nous
proposons pour suez et celle de la
continuité en matière d'emploi de
concurrence de recherche celle de la
confiance du management du corps social
et du conseil d'administration celle de
la compétitivité de la france qui
continuera à disposer de deux
locomotives sur un secteur d'avenir et
décisif pour notre économie
ceci permettrait de ne pas entrer dans
un feuilleton des structures de valeur
et d'emplois
beaucoup caricature la position des
fonds dans ce type d'opération pourtant
nous ne sommes pas ceux qui vous l'ont
démantelée suez ne sommes pas ceux qui
n'écoutent pas les syndicats nous sommes
pas ce qui me lançons la concurrence
dans les services essentiels
nous sommes ni dans une bataille
boursière n'ont ni dans une bataille
d'ego dans ce dossier nous faisons
partie de la solution pas du problème
permettez moi de redonner la parole à
dominique il faut conclure en trois mots
donc je souhaiterais pour conclure dire
qu'évidemment cette ambition n'est
atteignable que si suez et veolia
trouvent un accord dans une démarche
responsable et constructive nous ne
croyons pas à un capitalisme hostile
nous n'investissons nous mêmes que dans
des sociétés qui veulent travailler avec
nous et qui nous choisissent comme
partenaire et avec l'accord des
syndicats et des instances
représentatives du personnel
nous savons parce qu'on a une expérience
très longue de plus de 30 ans sur ces
secteurs que 70% des fusions
acquisitions ne réussissent pas ou très
peu et que c'est particulièrement vrai
des opérations hostiles où il n'y a pas
de volonté partagée sur un projet
industriel commun les entreprises ne
sont pas des constructions
intellectuelles ou financières ce sont
des collectivités humaines et seulement
humaines est grandement humaine aussi
pour nous le soutien du management de
suez de ces syndicats de ses clients et
de son conseil d'administration est
essentielle je vous remercie de votre
attention et nous sommes à votre
disposition pour répondre à toutes vos
questions
mais merci merci à vous donc je vais
j'ai donné la parole aux trois
rapporteurs de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable on va peut-être
commencer par madame on va peut-être
commencer par la dame mais j'ai donné la
parole à mme perreault et a peur de ce
gilet voilà quatre fois les toits du
doigt par le 4e chrono
merci président merci présidente madame
la présidente je viens d'entendre vos
arguments qu'ils sont plutôt rassurants
mais permettez moi de vous lire mes
interrogations ardien ans à l'époque
axa a investi en 2007 dans la saur en
endettant très fortement l'entreprise
puis en l'abandonnant à ses créanciers
en 2013
cette expérience prouve que les métiers
de l'eau et des déchets n'apporte pas
les rendements financiers exigés par les
fonds comme les vôtres en tout cas pas
dans les délais de vos investisseurs de
vos investissements par dont cinq à sept
ans qu'est ce qui vous dit qu'il en
serait différemment avec suez
pouvez-vous nous garantir que vous
seriez que vous ne seriez pas tenté de
vendre les plus belles filiale de suez
pour satisfaire les objectifs de
rentabilité de vos investisseurs nous
comprenons que vous investissez pour une
période de 5 7 ans ce qui est très court
pour les métiers de comme ceux de suez
qu'est ce qui nous dit que vous ne
revendre et pas l'entreprise à un
actionnaire étranger à l'issue et puis
une autre aussi ardillon a investi dans
la société photo ni ce qu'elle cherche
aujourd'hui à revendre la société semble
être en difficulté financière avec un
montant de dette environ quatorze fois
son ebita ce qui est comparable à la
dette de la saur lorsque vous étiez
actionnaire qu'est ce qui nous garantit
que vous ne direz pas la dette de suez
si vous arrivez à l'acquérir merci merci
on va passer la parole à catherine
fournier en visio catherine nous tendons
we re bonjour la présidente présente
bonjour mesdames messieurs eh bien je
voudrais revenir un petit peu sur sur le
fil samedi sur la vision que vous avez
réellement pour l'entreprise suez en
effet l'ensemble des personnes que nos
commissions ont auditionné et des
interlocuteurs invité dans le cadre du
comité de suivi estime qu'une fusion
entre entreprises et la présidente le
rappeler ne peut réussir sans amis
qualité d'une part et sans vision
partagée du projet d'entreprise de
l'autre dans le cadre de votre offre
émise avec le fonds américain j aie pis
pensez vous que ces conditions soient
remplies en particulier partagez vous
avec votre partenaire américain il
serait redondant sur les inquiétudes de
ma collègue et d'une paire aud une
vision commune pour suez
quel serait le rôle respectif des deux
sens en tant qu'actionnaire majoritaire
et comment votre intérêt pour les
activités de suez en matière de services
à l'environnement se justifie t-il en
particulier quelle est l'expérience ou
l' expertise d'art dian dans le secteur
français de l'eau à force à voir ce ter
qui implique la gestion
d'infrastructures coûteuse et de
personnels qualifiés
pourrez-vous rivaliser avec un majeur
établie de longue date sur le marché
telles que veolia
voilà je vous remercie merci monsieur
favre monsieur gilles abry oui de madame
la présidente je voudrais vous rappeler
mais vous le saviez déjà que nous avons
entendu tout à l'heure
le représentant du fonds meridiam qui se
propose lui aussi d'intervenir dans ce
dossier complexe et nous avons écouté
avec attention les propos du dirigeant
de ce fonds qui nous a d'abord rappelé
très précisément qu'elle s'était qu'elle
était seule expérience dans le domaine
de l'eau et qui nous a présenté très
précisément ce qui était son projet
d'entreprise dans le cadre de cette
opération
je dois dire que tout à l'heure vous
vous nous avait vanté avec beaucoup de
conviction votre engagement sur une
entreprise française
vous aviez une ambition pour l'entrepôt
de l'entreprenariat français et donc que
vous vouliez donc le bien et rien que le
bien de la société suez reste que je
n'ai pas trouvé dans vos propos la
précision que j'attendais dans d'abord
ça vient d'être évoqué le fait que la
proposition vous faites est une
proposition et on en est dans ce dossier
où on a souvent confondu les
propositions les pré offres et les
offres d'acquisition les offres d'achat
il est important si vous voulez que nous
sachions précisément à quel niveau se
trouve la proposition est donc dans ce
contexte précis vous faites de surcroît
une offre avec un fonds d'investissement
américain dont nous n'avons pas entendu
beaucoup parlé tout à l'heure vous ne
vais pas dit grand chose mais il est
quand même à vos côtés sur ce fond
pourquoi est ce que par exemple
le fond vous représentez ne se porte pas
seul acquéreur des actions dans ce
dossier et puis enfin je souhaiterais et
c'est un point important pour le sénat
vous savez que notre intérêt pour ce
dossier tient bien évidemment au fait
que la société suez comme d'ailleurs
c'est et veolia sont deux majors de
l'eau de l'assainissement des déchets en
france et donc il est normal que le
parlement s'y intéresse mais également
il est important que nous ayons quelques
assurances sur l'avenir notamment de
toutes les personnes qui travaillent
dans la société suez et c'est également
une de nos préoccupations
sur ce point précis j'aimerais également
avoir toute explication qui je vous
remercie
ggd merci monsieur le président madame
la présidente avant de déposer votre
offre donc avec jaïbi à lui également
mené une telle réflexion concernant
notamment les engagements comme mon
collègue l'indiqué par rapport aux
nature des activités notamment et puis
au maintien de l'emploi et notamment
aussi sur la recherche et développement
qui aujourd'hui est un secteur qui
questionnent beaucoup dans le cadre de
cette de ce projet de fusion quelle est
votre réflexion
donc sur ce sujet là est il correct
également de s'interroger sur la cession
de la branche eau de suez et pourriez
vous garantir l'intégrité du groupe donc
dans son périmètre actuel d'ims cadre de
l'ensemble des démarches qui sont en
cours et à l'issue donc de cette
opération
avez vous échangé à ce sujet donc avec
le ministère de l'économie
ou d'autres représentants des pouvoirs
publics est ce que pouvez-nous nous
inquiéter indiquer la nature de vos
relations
plus généralement quelle a été l
accompagnement et la réceptivité de
l'état dans le processus d'élaboration
de votre offre
nous avons eu également un échange assez
construit avec monsieur l'estrade et
récemment
est-ce que vous pouvez nous indiquer
également dans ce cadre si vous avez eu
des relations particulières donc avec
lui notamment par rapport aux
perspectives qui qui sont évoqués
aujourd'hui et notamment sur les futures
cessions d'actifs ces cessions d'actifs
qui de toute façon seront forcément un
objet particulier par rapport à
l'analyse de la concurrence sur le plan
de l'europe merci on va vous laisser
répondre à cette première salve de
questions voilà mais y en aura d'autres
tout est alors je vais essayer de
répondre à un certain nombre de
questions et puis je passerai bien sûr
la parole à mathias pour pour plusieurs
questions en particulier sur certains
sujets peut-être quand même si je peux
me permettre une minute de 2h10 de
redonner comment dire
le paysage financier nous ne sommes pas
un fond je le répète c'est très
important
nous sommes un groupement de sociétés de
gestion
donc on a en ce sens si vous voulez si
on regarde l'actionnariat des trois
groupes dont on parle parce qu'on a
parlé de chaises de veolia mais il ya
aussi angie il est toi même très
intéressant si vous voulez de voir que
si on nous a similar dian un fonds à
leur veolia est détenu à 90% par des
fonds déjà et à 83% par des fonds
étrangers
c'est la situation de la bourse pour
suez avec l'achat effectivement du bloc
de 29,9 suez est devenu affiliés à
veolia et donc effectivement
suez n'est plus posséder on va dire que
à 50 % par des fonds
nous appelons ça des sociétés de gestion
des soucis de gestion qui gère un
certain nombre ce qu'on appelait avant
excusez moi c'est une seconde j'ai mon
âge des opcvm des organismes de
placement collectif en valeurs
mobilières
mais qui souvent n'ont pas de
personnalité morale donc sauté par
gestion et c'est en ce sens que j'ai dit
que leur madame la présidente que hardy
en est comparable
amundi on est moins gros bien évidemment
et plus spécialisés sur des
investissements de long terme et donc
angie et lui est détenue à 70% par des
fonds excusez moi moi je dirais des
sociétés de gestion dont bien sûr 64%
par des étrangers puisque les sociétés
de gestion étrangères seront des volumes
beaucoup plus grande que vous le savez
les sociétés de gestion françaises
donc quand on a un débat sur la
détention dans des fonds par des
sociétés étrangères
il faut déjà un petit peu resituer ce
paysage qui est qu'effectivement ces
sociétés et ces sociétés sont
quelquefois disons un dialogue comme
vous l'avez vu assez difficile même avec
leurs actionnaires pourquoi mais parce
qu'il ya des spécialistes de la gestion
active activistes c'est ce fameux fonds
activiste doté des hedge fund qui ne
font que de l'arbitrage et la différence
justement entre art dian et ses
actionnaires qui sont cotées en bourse
fin qui sont qui n'ont métiers et la
chambre bourse est justement la longueur
de la détention des actifs
c'est c'est un point qui est essentiel
ardien investis à long terme alors que
les sociétés de gestion dite
traditionnelle qui font tourner leurs
portefeuilles rapidement et ou bien tout
simplement gère ce qu'on appelle des
fonds indiciels
c'est à dire où finalement le fond ne
représente que le poids respectif des
entreprises mais dans un indice boursier
mais ne pourra pas dire qu'ils
connaissent de manière approfondie et la
stratégie de l'entreprise
voilà alors pour ce qui est donc de la
sortie
et dans le cas de suez et donc de notre
vision à long terme et amicale nous
l'avons dit au management et à
l'intersyndicale que suez pouvait avoir
vocation bien évidemment à long terme à
revenir en bourse de paris d'ici
quelques années
voilà donc ça c'est très important de
comprendre que les métiers que nous
pratiquons d'investissement sont des
métiers à long terme amicaux en
partenariat avec les dirigeants des
entreprises et bien évidemment les
syndicats je vais répondre à votre
question sur photonis madame le ou la
rapportrice je sais plus comment on dit
au féminin alors puisque j'ai l'occasion
d'en parler je vous en parlais très très
en détail nous avons initié le processus
de cession de photonis entreprises
françaises spécialisées l'optronique
qu'on détenait depuis dix ans vous voyez
on peut pas nous accuser de court terme
et on a impliqué tous les acteurs
industriels français lors de du début de
la du process de cession est thales et
safran ils ont tous deux refusé de
s'intéresser au rachat de cette
entreprise qui pourtant une très belle
entreprise
nous avons travaillé depuis le départ en
étroite collaboration avec les services
de l'état pour les tenir informés tout
au long du processus de cession et nous
avons obtenu le feu vert du trésor et de
la dg ce qui nous paraissait donc au
bout de 18 mois être quelque chose de
donc de très favorable à l'issue du
parcours de 18 mois ce qui est
intéressant c'est que l'entreprise tv
dagne france et croyez moi bien je ne
milite pour personne n'est certainement
pas pour ce qu'il n'est pas français
mais quand même télé dang france est
présent en france
c'est une société française filiale de
télé dans une technologie incorporée
heated qui a fait part de son intérêt
d'acquérir photonis en apportant toutes
les garanties demandées par l'état pour
préserver ses intérêts ça a été le cas
de tout l'été dernier et avec des droits
de veto avec la présence de l'abbé pays
aux côtés de télé down qui avaient un
taux garanti sur sa participation et
toledano est déjà très bien ancré dans
le paysage français puisque telle est
dan fournit des pièces pour les
sous-marins nucléaires français les
barracuda et avait obtenu en juillet
2019 madame la rapportrice un an avant
une autorisation du même gouvernement
pour acheter une entreprise en france
il s'agit d' oldham simmtronics qui est
présente à arras et cette société est
une spécialiste des détecteurs de gaz et
flammes hautes performances et fournit
aussi la dg donc vous comprenez bien que
on a été un petit peu surpris d'avoir
donc un veto sur la vente at all down
alors je ne sais pas et je suis certaine
que vous avez des chiffres que dans
lesquelles vous avez toute confiance
mais je peux vous le confirmer
la société en aucun cas n'a 14 fois
limite d âge je sais pas d'où d'où vient
cette menace est absolument pas le cas
puisque il est question de la vendre en
ce moment à peu près à 9 x 2 vous pensez
bien que ce n'est pas les chiffres ne
concordent pas chez pac qui a dit ça
mais en tout cas ce n'est pas la réalité
du tout de la société je leur ai pas dit
une très belle société et nous l'avons
gardé dix ans voilà alors ensuite je
vais répondre aux questions sur l'état
l'état a joué un rôle tout à fait
positif vous vous souvenez sur la
question veolia suez c'est à dire qu'il
a été demandé aux sociétés veolia et
angie de prendre plus de temps et je
pense que c'était un élément essentiel
de l'intervention à l'époque de l'état
de dire ça le seul contact en tout cas
mais seuls contacts ont été avec à
l'époque avec le ministère de l'économie
quand on a compris
disons vers la mi-septembre que
effectivement il pouvait y avoir
place pour une offre alternative et donc
ça a été le contact que j'ai eu avec le
ministère de l'économie
voilà mais je crois qu'il n'y avait pas
de volonté au niveau de l'état d'avoir
une précipitation de de la session de ce
blog ce qui explique l'attitude
effectivement des 2 2 ou 3 représentants
de l'état le 5 octobre au conseil de
dungey jeu nous n'avons je n'ai pas eu
bien que connaissant personnellement
géant mestrallet je n'ai pas eu de
contact direct avec les pour répondre
très précisément cette question mais je
sais qu'il était effectivement très
désireux de voir une solution amicale et
en concert avec la direction et des
syndicats de suez
voilà je laisserais mathias répondre
tous les autres je voudrais juste dire
un mot puisque vous parlez de meridiam
meridiam et donc une société qui gère
des fonds dans l'infrastructure
nous savons simplement que on pense que
l'investissement moyen de meridiam est
de l'ordre de 65 millions d'euros dans
les sociétés 65 millions d'euros
cela sent pas énorme
on va le dire ou pas significatif par
rapport à une société comme suez
je dirais que nous-mêmes chaire dian
avons investi 16 milliards d'euros dans
les entreprises d'infrastructure dans
lesquelles nous sommes investisseurs
depuis quelques années donc s'est
substantiellement supérieur et donc je
sais un seule chose qui m'interrogent
dans ce cette question c'est la
dimensionnement respectifs de meridiam
et de et de suez quel que soit
d'ailleurs sa taille
voilà j'ai passé la parole à mathias
burghardt et on est tout à fait ouvert à
toutes les questions autre que vous
voudriez nous poser alors peut être
répondre à la question de la sorte
puisque et c'est une question qui est
qui revient pas mal
la sort n'a pas été un succès et nous
avons perdu de l'argent
c'est un fait mais je voulais vous
rappeler quelques éléments de deux
vérifiable la saur est une filiale de
séché environnement et la caisse des
dépôts
si nous n'étions canal un actionnaire
minoritaire d'ailleurs nous avions agi
toujours un investisseur responsable et
à ce jour là sort est toujours un acteur
important avec une part de marché
sensiblement égale à celle qui était la
sienne
au moment où nous étions actionnaires
lorsqu'ils ce qui est intéressant de ce
que nous avons analysé de cette
expérience difficile
d'abord nous avons investi juste avant
la crise financière et nous avons très
vite retrouvé face à une situation
économique extrêmement dégradé et à d un
marché de l'eau en france qui était en
train d'évoluer puisque vous savez
qu'ils viennent certainement de
dévolution de réglementation sur l'eau
notamment sur sur la collecte un certain
nombre de taxes
ensuite c'était la saur était et est
toujours un acteur essentiellement
français positionné essentiellement sur
le marché de l'eau en france
vous savez que c'est un marché mature
c'est un marché qui qui a une
décroissance structurelle depuis des
années les volumes d'eau pour des
raisons environnementales
couplé à une à une baisse effectivement
démarche puisque vous savez qu'en france
nous avons un système d'affermage dans
lequel ce n'est pas la société
gestionnaire qui investit mais les
collectivités locales
donc il est essentiel pour traverser les
cycles et pour faire face à cette
structure avec structure de marché en
qui est mature voir en déclin d'avoir
des relais de croissance à
l'international
le deuxième élément le troisième élément
c'est que et là aussi c'est une leçon
que nous avons tirée le rapprochement de
séché environnement et la saur ne s'est
révélée une mauvaise idée
dans les cultures et les modes de
travail des deux entreprises étaient
différentes
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire sur le
sol
la taille la culture je crois que
c'était très difficile de ces très vite
révélée difficile d'intégrer les deux
entreprises nous avons dominique a
répondu sur sur meridiam ses effectifs
dire pourquoi ça ne peut pas être très
précis au jour d'aujourd'hui non plus il
présente aussi vous parler de deux gp
qui est qui est notre partenaire gp a
été choisi par par suez
ils ont organisé un concours de beauté
comme on dit et bien sûr ils nous ont
consultés sur sur la qualité des
différents partenaires qui pouvait nous
rejoindre gp c'est une société c'est un
leader mondial dans le domaine des
infrastructures
ils ne font que de l'infrastructure
n'existe que dans le domaine des
infrastructures est encore dans
l'infrastructure
ils investissent que dans deux domaines
l'énergie l'environnement et les
transports
c'est une société dont qui existe depuis
2006 et qui investit eux
son premier premier continent où ils
investissent c'est l'europe avec plus de
40% de ses investissements qui ont été
réalisés en europe avec un montant
d'investissement sensiblement égal au no
puisqu'on parle de 15,15 milliards
d'euros rien qu'en europe c'est une
société qui partage les mêmes critères
de long terme et 2 et 2 et de critères
d'intégration au psg comme nous c'est
aussi une entreprise qui a une vision
très industrielle c'est un héritage de
ses des anciens de 2 dudit water de que
nous c'est quelqu'un que nous
connaissons bien puisque nous avons
travaillé avec eux de remettre les
coactionnaires avec les deux d'entre eux
c'est ça l'important d'une entreprise en
espagne qui s'appelle ces lâches et qui
gère le tout tout ce qui est tout ce qui
est tous les centres de stockage et de
transport de des hydrocarbures c'est
donc c'est une entreprise totalement
essentiel et nous avons été co
actionnaires pendant de nombreuses
années et c'est une entreprise qui est
donc on sait très bien qu'on peut
travailler très bien ensemble
donc pour le projet donc bon sur la
rentabilité et plusieurs questions sur
la rentabilité l'infrastructure dans les
fonds d'infrastructure sont des fonds à
15 ans nous avons des fonds d'une durée
de 15 ans et encore nous pouvons comme
c'est parfois le cas créer des fonds de
continuation c'est-à-dire pour continuer
à détenir ces entreprises lorsqu'elles
sont très stratégique je donne quelques
exemples tours-bordeaux lala le projet
avec que nous avons réalisé avec avec
vinci d'ailleurs grid et à mesure je
n'ai rejoint quelques quelques mois
après l'a88 une autoroute en normandie
ces sont des sociétés ou alors calista
ce sont des ces sondés placent en
énergies renouvelables sont toutes des
entreprises que nous détenons depuis
plus de dix ans et que nous avons qui
maintenant sont détenues par un fonds
qui sont gérés par l'anp à fond de
continuation
voilà un peu pour vous donner un peu en
matière d'horizon en ce qui concerne la
rentabilité et pour revenir aux propos
que je tenais au début je pense que les
infrastructures nécessitent un nouveau
mode de partenariat
je prends pour preuve évidemment
l'exemple de adp que de mentionner
dominique mais nous avons récemment une
dernière opération nous avons investi
aux côtés des collectivités locales
allemand de basse-saxe dans une société
qui s'appelle e double veux qu'ils aient
tout le monopole sur cette région là de
de tous qui électricité gaz mais aussi
la fra structure de télécommunications
les collectivités locales ont organisé
un concours de beauté elle détenait 100
% de la société
il voulait chercher un partenaire pour
être partenaire minoritaire donc dans ce
cas nous sommes partenaires minoritaires
mais influents puisqu'ils nous ont
choisis pour les aider à développer
cette entreprise dans le cadre d'un
projet de transition énergétique et donc
notre rentabilité tout à fait compatible
avec celle des collectivités locales
ce n'est pas un exemple isolé puisque
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
les départements nous ont choisis dans
adp
nous sommes le partenaire de la ville de
milan encore une fois la ville de milan
est majoritaire nous sommes minoritaires
pour les aider à développer les reports
de milan donc c'est une nouvelle forme
de partenariat et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui le volonté de détenir
seul de contrôler seul est une est une
une mauvaise une mauvaise idée lorsqu'il
s'agit de coller de l'infrastructure
essentielle parce que personne ne peut
prendre la responsabilité tout seuls et
personne n'a le le savoir-faire nilan il
a l'intelligence uniquement pour gérer
ce genre d'infrastructure qui sont
complètement intégrés à des territoires
donc pour reprendre la question pourquoi
j'y aille pays n'y est pas allé tout
seul parce que j'ai pu partager
exactement le même avis ils sont
pourtant très beau en termes
d'investissements d'infrastructures mais
ils comprennent que c'est une très
mauvaise idée d'être de vouloir investir
tout seul dans une entreprise de
l'importance de suez et rechercher des
partenaires ils ont été bien sûr eu nous
ont dit tout de suite
nous on veut être à parité avec vous ni
plus ni moins et bien sûr nous sommes
ouverts à un capital qui sera
majoritairement français et à accueillir
des investisseurs institutionnels
français publics ou privés
vous voyez c'est aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il ya une vision un peu passéiste de
considérer que pour contrôler des entre
des entreprises et encore plus des
infrastructures essentielles
il faut être tout seul et à voir le
console tout seul il faut avoir de
nouveaux partenariats publics et privés
et moi je crois que l'évolution vous le
savez puisque vous avez examiner le
projet de des aéroports je pense que les
collectivités locales ont une influence
décisive dans les infrastructures qui
sont au plus près des territoires
alors je ne sais pas si je joue bly
certaines questions sur sur les salariés
je pense que le mieux c'est c'est de
leur poser la question mais je crois que
à plusieurs reprises ils ont marqué leur
leur souhait d'avoir un projet
alternatif qui préserve l'indépendance
de suez moi je les ai rencontrés à deux
reprises et je pense qu'ils ont vraiment
le désir de dako de 2,2 d'accueillir un
projet qui soit qu'ils soient alternatif
et qui préserve l'indépendance de suez
qui soit aussi ambitieux il faut
absolument que ce projet soit est une
cohérence industrielle donc c'est au
management de suez le proposer et il
faut qu'il soit ambitieux pour les
raisons que je vous donne c'est à dire
que le marché français est un marché mûr
si on veut si on veut avoir des
entreprises qui continuent à investir
continuez nouvelle veux parler de
recherche la recherche est fondamentale
suez et particulièrement en avance en
matière de recherche
il investit proportionnellement plus que
son concurrent est donc cette recherche
elle ne peut s'alimenter que sur si elle
a évidemment un contour suffisant si
elle peut nourrir réseau international
les marchés que sont l'amérique du nord
l'asie sont essentiels pour nourrir la
recherche je pas si je me dis quelque
chose juste vous nous avez demandé aussi
le seul sénateur à juste titre les
précisions sur sur suez et notre offre
à ce stade on ne peut pas être très
précis ce qui est précis c'est ce qui a
été publique c'est à dire le communiqué
de presse de veolia du 26 janvier vous
le savez 2021 qui a listé les actifs de
suez que veolia considère comme
stratégique
donc il a listé il ya donc l'eau en
espagne
lochies l'île aux états unis les déchets
au royaume uni et les déchets en
australie donc la liste des actifs
stratégiques
désiré par veolia a été donné
officiellement dans un communiqué de
presse
nous avons demandé au management de suez
effectivement qu'est ce que ça
représentait en volume alors ils nous
ont confirmé que cela représentait
seulement 4 milliards 6 d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires sur un total de 17 18
milliards d'euros du groupe suez
et je vais vous dire la première
réflexion je dirais de pur bon sens se
dire à quoi bon une telle opération
hostile on va le dire maintenant un
moment elle cherche être amical là on ne
sait plus trop où on est sur 100% du
capital s'il n'y a que 30 % de
l'activité qui intéresse veolia c'est
joli c'est vraiment des raisonnements de
pur bon sens et puis en tant que
française résidente française
contribuables via et vieilles français
et je me mets aussi à la place je vais
vous dire des salariés de suez france
quelle surprise également de constater
qu'aucun active de suez en france n'est
considéré comme stratégique pour veolia
jeu je mets à la place du personnel de
suez c'est quand même un petit peu un
petit peu désagréable de lire que ce qui
est stratégique ne concerne absolument
pas les 48 salariés quarante mille
salariés c'est à peu près la moitié de
l'effectif global de suez voilà donc
c'est pour dire que aujourd'hui tout le
monde sait qu effectivement loupé a donc
a été lancé par veolia et que dans cet
opéra
la commission de la concurrence à
bruxelles n'acceptera pas que le groupe
reste avec to touch est ce donc
les discussions sont faites entre les
deux groupes ou en tout cas on espère
qu'elles seront fait tantôt d'être
groupe pour aboutir à quelque chose qui
sera très bien pour l'ensemble des
salariés en particulier certainement
tous les tous les salariés français
voilà ça je voulais le dire parce que
c'est pas du tout pour ne veux pas dire
mais simplement il ya des désirs des
deux côtés et je pense qu'à un moment il
faut effectivement que les deux côtés
arrive à trouver un accord
voilà celui d'hier eh bien merci madame
la présidente merci monsieur on peut
peut-être commencer les questions moi je
vais avoir franck montaugé et ensuite
fabien gay dans le même ordre que tout à
l'heure
merci m'impressionne merci madame merci
monsieur pour vos explications
moi j'aurai deux questions à partir de
vos propos vous vous avez dit madame
nous sommes prêts à accompagner suez
dans le cadre d'un plan adapté tenant
compte de la nouvelle donne est un peu
avant vous disiez il ya place pour
veolia et suez en les recentrant sur
leurs points forts respectifs
ça fait écho à ce que vous venez de dire
à l'instant qu'aux commandes comment
voyez-vous et alors donc ça sous-entend
qu'il va falloir que les clés des
entreprises s'entendent
voilà pour ne pas faire un gros les
mêmes choses être fort sur leurs
secteurs respectifs
ça c'est pas craint sans conséquence sur
chacune des deux entreprises y compris
sur les personnels concernés
est-ce que vous conditionner la
poursuite de votre offre et de votre
participation à cette opération a
effectivement s'être restructurations
respectives des deux entreprises par
rapport à leur secteur
diddy stratégique et puis effectivement
ça part mal à partir de la fin de ce que
vous venez de dire de la position de
l'expression de
de veolia donc ça c'est ma c'est ma
première question est ma seconde de
questions je n'ai pas compris quel est
le montage exa entre votre entreprise et
j p quelle est la part de chacun d'eux
dans comment finalement arbitre ton des
exigences de rendement à moyen long
terme d'après ce que je vous avais dit
de votre façon de gérer les choses et
des exigences aiderait de rendement à
court terme eux voire très court terme
du 2g ip voilà ça je n'ai pas compris
donc si vous pouviez nous préciser les
choses ça serait ce serait utile je vous
remercie
fab a depuis des questions non fabien
gay dans ce cas puis notre collègue
kevin renaud garabédian par visio je
crois merci mesdames le président moi
aussi je suis très heureux de vous
rencontrer jamais eu cette occasion
puisque votre nom apparaît partout dans
beaucoup d'opérations on n'avait jamais
eu l'occasion d'échanger
je pense notamment à dp même si ça n'a
pas pu aboutir
et puis bon là j'ai une première
question est ce que ça n'arrive pas trop
tard ce que je juge heger j'ai
l'impression quand même malheureusement
que la faire pour veolia et est très
bien partie et c'est que cet opéra
hostile
je ne vois pas aujourd'hui en réalité
même si il ya une opposition officielle
on va dire du gouvernement la saisie des
marchés financiers etc
mais en réalité je vois pas comment on
va pouvoir s'y opposer parce qu'il n'y a
pas d'outil juridique aujourd'hui même
si on peut la retarder donc la question
c'est est ce que ça n'arrive pas trop
tard et puis la deuxième je vous donnais
le fond de ma pensée on ça fait
plusieurs auditions qu'on fait on a
entendu et veolia on entendu tout à
l'heure vos collègues de meridian même
si j'ai entendu vous n'étiez pas un
fonds d'investissement vous êtes comment
on appelle ça à oui c'est comme
technicienne surface et balayeur c'est
exactement la même chose mais on dit pas
le même mot à la fin le balayeur il a la
même peine mais il était cuit c'est une
surface donc société de gestion
franchement non mais je vous dis ça on a
entendu veolia on entendu mérian vous en
vous si on nous dit pas qui est qui
c'est exactement le même discours je
vous le dis assez sincèrement tout le
monde nous dit préservation de l'emploi
projets industriels mais dès qu'on
rentre dans le détail sur quel
investissement concret
on va avoir sur la recherche et
développement que voulez vous faire
c'est ça patauge un peu voilà et je vous
dis que vous soyez associé avec jp qui
est pas une entreprise philanthropique
j'ai regardé un peu j'ai cherché qui
aussi a priori un fonds de gestion
américain voilà donc qu'est ce qui fait
la différence entre véolia meridian et
votre offre à vous concrètement moi je
suis je vous le dis concrètement vous
avez compris plutôt pour une gestion
publique de tout ça et que si on compte
faire et qu'on laisse la gestion au
privé de l'eau de l'assainissement et
des déchets encore on va à la
catastrophe donc mais franchement je
voudrais savoir la différence fils qui a
un trop beau trois offres
voilà je vous remercie mais au plaisir
de vous rencontrer pour une prochaine
opération de l'opération merci fabien
evelyne renault garabédian
visioconférence en face de vous même
être évident
merci madame la présidente
l'autre proposition de partenariat avec
suez porte l origine non seulement sur
la cession de la branche de gestion de
l'eau française mais aussi sur d'autres
filiales à l'international en escale au
chili est également en grande bretagne
si un accord est finalement trouvé entre
veolia et suez
souhaiteriez-vous toujours vous porter
acquéreur des filiales aux gros que suez
détient à l'étranger et que veolia bien
entendu ne pourra pas conserver en
raison des règles concurrence y compris
mme dans le cas où la filiale suez au
franc ce serait finalement cédé à
meridian vous nous détailler quels sont
ses filiales et nos engagements à leur
égard merci ou evelyne enfin jean
baptiste blanc merci madame la
présidente madame la présidente
une observation une question
d'observation ce que je trouve
très intéressant qu'un acteur comme vous
puisse dire qu'il ya la place pour deux
champions mondiaux et nos voies
possibles pour que chacun soit puissant
très intéressant une étude parue ce jour
je les ai vus dans les échos simplement
présenté par l'économiste
patrice geoffron et alternant nous
invite aussi à réfléchir sur la taille
qu'est ce que la bonne taille et nous
met 6 notamment que l'effet de taille ne
s'impose pas forcément comme une
évidence que cela pourrait réduire
l'intensité de la concurrence et
pourrait aussi réduire les incitations à
l'innovation donc sur la taille c'est
très intéressant d'entendre dire qu'on
peut avoir la place pour deux et que big
n est pas beautiful
ma question maintenant est la suivante
c'est que c'est dans le prolongement de
mon collègue montaugé la propos de
jaypee mais on évoque aussi carlyle j'ai
lu ça qu'en est il et autrement dit en
clair qui aurait le contrôle de suez au
final autrement dit est-ce que ce serait
les français toujours merci oui il veut
donner la parole à didier mandelli merci
monsieur le président écouter la
présidente
on a bien entendu différents arguments
je pense que la différence notable avec
l'audition précédentes c'est que n'ont
pas tous la même définition du long
terme
pour vous c'est dix ans vous avez évoqué
cinq à sept ans avec la possibilité de
remises de cession en bourse à cette
échéance alors que meridiam
effectivement est plutôt sur des
investissements de long terme à hauteur
de 25 ans donc on n'a pas tous vous
notamment la même définition du long
terme ou à ma question elle rejoint
celle d'une collègue qui l'a posée
précédemment c'était simplement votre
intérêt dans le cas où l'opération de
veolia irait à son terme
votre intérêt pour quels actifs de suez
dans ce cadre là est-ce que
éventuellement vous êtes prêts malgré
tout à apprendre vous positionner face à
meridiam et puis évidemment sur les
autres actifs à l'étranger dont il ya
pour est ce être amené à ceux à se
défaire est-ce que vous confirmerez
votre intérêt pour une acquisition
partielle des activités
je vais juste rajouter quelques
questions si vous me le permettez
d'abord une question peut-être technique
mais je n'a du mal à comprendre ces
événements passés je voudrais revenir
sur l'offre de septembre lors des 10
journaux bien informer mieux informé que
la représentation nationale nous
indiquait que en septembre haarde y en
avait reçu un feu vert de bercy pour
déposer une offre alternative
ce même cette même chaîne d'information
nous indique kenji vous aurai prévenu
je ne sais pas par quels moyens et je
mets le conditionnel que votre offre
était considérée comme hostile et vous
aurez d inciter à proposer une offre
donc je voudrais savoir si c'est vrai si
ces éléments qui sont qui sont reportés
par par bfm d'ailleurs sont exacts ou
pas ce qu'on pourrait vraiment
comprendre cette affaire là la deuxième
question c'est effectivement rapport à
l'offre et aux discussions possibles
aujourd'hui il ya eu des discussions
entre veolia et suez
notamment il ya une dizaine de jours ce
fameux vendredi prêt au pays au pea
est ce que finalement les discussions
elle montrait des écarts sur les
périmètres que vous souhaitiez obtenir
est ce que finalement veolia veut tout
sauf ce que l'autorité de la concurrence
l'obligerait à vendre ou et puis est-ce
que vous de l'autre côté vous voulez
tout l'eau par exemple de façon
internationale
est-ce que c'est là dessus que porte
votre votre différence et puis dernière
question peut-être un peu provocante
madame la présidente mais aujourd'hui à
une op à suez et sous-offre puisque
voilà notoriété des marchés a accepté on
va considérer que l'offre suez et
sous-offre est ce que vous vous êtes
prête avec votre fonds à faire une
contre au pea
à vous faire je vais commencer par vous
répondre à vous puisque la question est
plus fraîche comme on dit c'est pas tout
à fait un feu vert que l'on a reçu en
septembre c'est c'est plutôt disons un
message comme quoi il était il est et il
était bien venu de faire de réfléchir
avec suez à une offre alternative
voilà on va le dire comme ça c'est à
dire que soit un jeu est fermée soit un
jeu il ya l'ouverture et effectivement
je fadi dans une situations dans
lesquelles il ya de l'ouverture
et comme je le dis l'intérêt de notre
solution est là je vais répondre un peu
à vous et à peu à monsieur la différence
je veux la faire très simple entre
veolia et hardy ans et que nous on est
français français je viens de vous dire
que veolia était possédé 75 % par des
fonds étrangers
alors donc c'est déjà une grande et une
grande différence
mais il y en ad'autres je reviendrai
tout à l'heure là dessus mais avant que
j'oublie de vous dire la grande
différence
et puis nous sommes effectivement des
investisseurs de très long terme
alors je reprends aussi je suis désolé
j'ai un peu dans le monde
mais quand vous me dites la définition
du long terme il ya quelqu'un d'autre
qui a posé la question là dessus sur 25
en cinq sets en je crois que mathias but
regarde a expliqué récemment de tout à
l'heure que nos fonds ont une durée de
15 ans ce qui est déjà très important
tout à l'heure je voulais dit les
actionnaires des sociétés cotées en
bourse tourner leurs portefeuilles tous
les six mois
donc on ne peut pas disons dire que les
sociétés de gestion comme les nôtres
sont des investisseurs de court terme
c'est tout l'inversé
nous sommes des investisseurs de long
terme nous avons la même gouvernance que
des sociétés cotées en bourse
la seule chose c'est que l'horizon
d'investissement est justement beaucoup
plus long et ne nous sommes pas nous ne
sommes pas soumis
vous le savez à la dictature des
résultats trimestriels donc ça c'est
très important dans le cas également
vous voulez de il faut voir puisque je
vous dis que veolia appartient alors je
me suis fait chier
c'est 75% fin c'est écrasant le chiffre
de 2 à des tensions étrangères des
capitaux dans nos sociétés cotées en
bourse un mets donc quand vous mettez
suez ou dessous ça veut dire vous faites
aussi passé suez sous contrôle étranger
monsieur et ce n'est pas du conseil du
contrôle étranger privé voilà tandis que
notre solution c'est une solution de
capital à majorité français et même plus
français que maintenant puisque tout à
l'heure je vous ai dit que suez est
également à l'or grâce à l'achat on va
le dire le 30 % de veolia veolia est une
entité française niveau de sa structure
juridique mais par contre l'actionnariat
et étrangers voilà donc ça c'est
important et que donc 1
nous sommes un investissement de long
terme et le 25 ans bien sûr qu'on le
fait aussi monsieur monsieur des eaux et
meridiam n'en a pas la primeur il n'a
pas le monopole de l'investissement à 25
ans pourrait prendre une phrase célèbre
lorsque monsieur bur garde vous dit que
certaines autoroutes ont été prises et
mises dans un fonds spécial de
continuation c'est à dire que c'est
toujours hardy ans qui gère mais par
contre c'est passé sous de nouveaux
actionnaires dons de particuliers
exemple que tu as donné c'est le groupe
axa est un fonds de pension qui ont
acheté des actifs et c'est toujours
ardent qui les gère et donc on doit en
être à 20 ans à peu près de détention et
on pourra vous donner des chiffres très
précis si vous les voulez voilà l or
ensuite pour les déclarations suis
désolé je réponds un peu donc un peu
comme vos questions vous voulez pas
alors le journal en septembre
je les dis en fait ce qui c'est ce qui
s'est produit c'est que suez est quand
même une entreprise d'une certaine
taille elle et vous savez en
capitalisation elle est très proche de
veolia on parle de deux sociétés qui
finalement l'une je crois vos 13
milliards en bourse et l'autre 11
milliards on essaie des egos et c'est
pas c'est pas des sociétés très
différentes en termes de taille
voilà et je dirais même que la marge
bénéficiaire de suez est supérieure à
celle de veolia
bon alors ce qui s'est produit c'est que
effectivement on a compris le 4e soir là
je reviens
ce que vous disiez le 4 octobre au soir
que la société angie était pressé de
vendre
clairement il était pressé de vendre et
donc qu'effectivement la société nj
considérer qu'une la confirmation d'une
lettre d'intention pas rare d'y en
serait inamical
parce que l ils seraient 10 ont regardé
le lundi matin par le conseil
d'administration effectivement il y
aurait deux possibilités une qui
demandait je le répète pour 18 milliards
de chiffre d'affaires c'est quand même
assez difficile de faire un dieu dit lee
jones en l'espace d'une semaine en tout
cas ça serait pas sérieux et donc il
nous fallait six semaines de plus voilà
et donc c'est devant le refus de dungey
d'accepter ces délais qui étaient
demandés pourtant par le ministère de
l'économie que donc nous avons retiré le
dépôt d'une deuxième lettre d'offre
voilà donc ça ça c'est ça alors
maintenant pour la question des
périmètres
il faut que nous restions modeste c'est
à dire que nous avons deux groupes
industriels veolia et suez
nous avons veolia qui a aujourd'hui 29
9% de suez et donc il est il est très
clair que c'est à eux et c'est en
particulier à eux deux de discuter d'un
périmètre d'activité c'est eux qui
doivent le définir qui est un périmètre
qui sera viable qui sera pas un tout
petit suez qu'il soit quand même quelque
chose de très substantiels et donc il y
a toujours le point d'interrogation de
l'entente entre ces deux groupes à
définir ce n'est en aucun cas un groupe
comme hard y en à définir des périmètres
vous semble bien qu'on est actionnaire
ni de l'un ni de l'autre
c'est à eux est effectivement pour vous
préciser
suivant les résultats effectivement les
acheteurs de 2
nouveau suez peuvent être différent de
tout ce qu'on a envisagé même avant donc
il ne faut pas on ne peut pas c'est pour
ça que je le répète on ne peut pas être
plus précis que ce qu'on ait aujourd'hui
puisque ça résultera de l'accord entre
les entre les deux groupes
voilà alors les rendements les
rendements je veux dire les rendements
les rendements en infrastructures on va
être quand vous dit c'est de l'ordre de
8%
ça n'a rien à voir avec les rendements
qu'on demande dans d'autres catégories
de d'investissement que nous demandent
d'ailleurs nos investisseurs comme vous
le savez les taux longs sont
complètement ou négatif où le taux à 30
ans de la bundesbank est négatif encore
le taux français est à 0 40
donc il y a beaucoup d'investisseurs
institutionnels dans le monde qui
cherchent à rehausser le rendement
globaux de les actifs en investissements
dans le non coté dans les
infrastructures dans l'immobilier de
façon à ce que le rendement global de
leur portefeuille soit réhaussée par le
rendement d'une petite partie de 10 à 15
% puisque ces investissements non cotés
sont toujours quand même une partie
mineure des investissements globaux vous
le savez les assureurs en france n'ont
que 2 % de leurs actifs qui sont dans
des actifs dits nos côtés ou
infrastructures donc oui je vous donnais
un chiffre là la bourse américaine
depuis 1er janvier a monté de 4 76% en
six semaines
alors si on annualise le rendement sur
la nes est bien supérieur aux 8 % que je
viens de citer
donc tout est relatif un taux de 8% est
un taux qui est tout à fait correct
on dit que les bourses sur très très
long terme les bourses fond on va dire
400 points de base au dessus de au
dessus du libor entre 400 points de base
et 500 points de base donc se les dire
8%
ça veut dire que c'est des actifs un peu
plus à risque donc il mérite une petite
prime de rendement mais c'est pas non
plus des rendements disons
kiki qui sont mauvais pour l'entreprise
voilà je crois que j'ai beaucoup parlé
je te laisse la parole pour tout le
reste
non peut-être de commentaire donc juste
pour rappeler effectivement là là le
pourquoi de jpg et paie donc est un
partenaire que nous avons je crois que
on a souligné que les importantes
l'entreprise puisse continuer à se
développer à l'international notamment
savait que que suez est très présente
aux états unis c'était une étape marché
aussi extrêmement important vous les
besoins d'investissement sont
considérables donc le management de suez
et nous-mêmes étions sensible au fait
que j'aie ip pouvait nous aider à
accélérer justement la croissance aux
états unis car là il n'a jamais été
approché par nous nous avons d'ailleurs
formellement démenti cette information
pour effectivement essayé d'éclairer ce
qui est sûr qu'on soit et pas très
facile la différence entre meridiam
alger ip un art dian les investisseurs
sont les mêmes
il faut bien être conscient c'est
toujours des caisses de retraite ou de
l'assurance vie donc pour pour
l'essentiel donc c'est il ya on a beau
vous dire que c'est très différent c'est
une c'est une c les mêmes investisseurs
les attend de retour sont similaires et
ceux qui ensuite change c'est la qualité
des équipes
la vision en ce qui nous concerne nous
avons une différence effectivement dans
ce projet c'est que nous avons été
toujours été très claire nous
n'investirons pas si nous n'avons pas
une adhésion non seulement du management
mais une adhésion et pas juste une
consultation des salariés sachent on a
été très clair avec les salariés et
là-dessus il n'y a pas d'ambiguïté
donc nous adhérons un projet industriel
cohérent nous serons vigilants la
cohérence industrielle qui rêve pourrait
résulter de ces négociations donc on ne
nieront pas s'il ne ce projet nous
paraît pas suffisamment ambitieux et
cohérent et je vous confirme que nous
sommes pas candidats au rachat
d'actifs qui pourraient tomber
par ci par là ce ne sommes pas ne sommes
pas candidats nous avons toujours être
aux côtés de suez d'ailleurs au départ
nous avons proposé une solution
alternative qui était suez dans son
ensemble dans le cadre du projet suez
2030 pour répondre à la question de la
contrôler a que vous avez posé madame la
présidente je dois préciser que monsieur
frérot m'a appelé le 2 février en me
demandant mon soutien pour que suez et
lui ait des discussions amicales
je lui ai dit que je ferais tout pour
pousser suez avoir des discussions
amicales avec lui c'était donc le 2
février
il a rencontré monsieur camus le 5
et vous pensez bien que donc on était
complètement surpris et plus qu'étonné
du dépôt d'offres le lundi donc 8
février
voilà donc simplement il ya eu un effet
de surprise sur sept au pea inamicale on
va dire ou hostiles parce que de toute
bonne foi
j'ai bien cru le 2 février que qu'il
souhaitait une solution amicale voilà
alors pour dire
il n'ya pas nous ne travaillons pas
aujourd'hui ou alors sur un projet de
contre-opa voilà c'est tout ce qu'on
peut dire pour être sincère il ya encore
quelques demandes de questions je fais
de donner la parole à daniel grémillet
pardon oui merci madame la présidente
madame à présent moi je voudrais
rebondir sur la question de ma collec
tout à l'heure parce que je j'ai pas
compris vraiment une réponse très claire
sur le niveau d'investissement le sujet
de l'eau il était inscrit il s'écrit
dans les territoires vous savez que au
niveau du cdas est un sujet très
sensible et quand on voit les
investissements qui ont été faits par
les collectivités il s'écrit au temps
long or bon dans ce que j'ai compris de
vos réponses en a marre présente
monsieur on l'a plutôt vu sur un temps
court et cette question est d'autant
plus essentiel aujourd'hui on est dans
une espèce d'inquiétude voire
spéculatifs de l'eau bien plus que par
le passé
donc c'est devenu un enjeu majeur y
compris notre dans nos territoires et à
travers vos propos si vous voulez donner
confiance aux collectivités mais il faut
éclairer un peu plus ce temps long parce
que sinon votre propos on est
quelques-uns à avoir par définition
qu'on est comme d'un commission des
affaires économiques ou développement
durable on est tous sur nos territoires
est le discours de dire on garde le
siège en la recherche on l'entend
toujours
puis on sait comment parfois ça se
termine parce que c'est la vie
donc il nous faudrait plus de certitudes
sur les investissements elle temps long
je faisais juste pardonnez-moi mena le
président fait juste donner la parole à
marie noëlle lienemann qui est en visio
voilà pour cette question et voilà le
même sujet
pardon d'accord je ne vais pas rajouter
à ce qu'a dit fabien gay moi je suis pas
mal très inquiète
et d'ailleurs ce que vient dé daniel
grémillet vers la vulnérabilité d'un
secteur stratégique comme celui d'auch
qui va être de plus en plus vulnérable à
des pratiques spéculatives et financière
et pour ma part mais ça ne tiendra
personne ici je suis pour une gestion
publique directement par un opérateur
public qui peut d'ailleurs être
ambitieux à l'international et j'oserais
comprendre vous nous dites madame que
votre fonds est français mais je
voudrais comprendre pourquoi aller
chercher un fonds américain en
l'occurrence gip des comptes vous nous
donnez l'argumentaire vous nous
expliquer que comme vous voulez vous
développer à l'international
il faudrait un fonds américain ce qui
n'est pas la preuve il ya des tas de
développement à l'international avec des
fonds qui ne sont pas d'origine
américaine et d'autre part s'attend à
dire quand même que dans votre
préoccupation de rendement parce que
j'ai surtout entendu des analyses de
placements financiers plus que de deux
jumeaux stratégie industrielle s'attend
quand même à dire que vous êtes attaché
au développement à l'international
quand on vous écoute beaucoup plus
d'importance qu'à son rayonnement de la
gestion de l'eau et par ailleurs des
déchets dans le cas de jeu suez sur le
territoire national et en europe
- la question que je me pose c'est
pourquoi aller chercher un partenaire
américain et après nous expliquer que
vous êtes un fonds français
moi je trouve que ça nous donne une
grande vulnérabilité alors certes tous
les fonds sont liées à des à des
rendements à des comment s'appelle des
des retraités des choses comme ça enfin
celui qui maîtrise le fond et quand même
essentiel dans les choix stratégiques
pourquoi aller chercher un opérateur
américain sujet
oui merci de questions très rapide
vous avez parlé du marché mature à
l'heure actuelle au niveau national donc
la nécessité d'aller à l'international
en termes de développement ceci dit sur
le marché français aujourd'hui on
assiste à une évolution des dsp vert en
fait de nouvelles approches de régis où
les opérateurs sont amenés là à voir une
nouvelle offre de services notamment en
termes de compétences et d'ingénierie
est ce que cette orientation a été
travaillée en particulier quel est votre
regard sur ce sujet là et puis pour
clôturer en fait qu'est ce que vous
espérez aujourd'hui est ce que vous
espérez la nomination d'un médiateur
dans ce dossier là pour le faire évoluer
favorablement
on va vous laisser répondre maintenant
alors on va vous laisser répondre à ces
trois dernières questions
je crois que nous serions très heureux
pour répondre à la dernière question qui
la nomination d'un médiateur
quand les situations deviennent un peu
aussi difficile
ça peut ça peut être extrêmement positif
qu'un médiateur soit soit nommé alors je
crois que sur l'étang long des
investissements on a répondu répondu
plusieurs fois que vous pouvez avoir un
investissement entre 15 et 25 ans sans
aucune chance à 15 sujet sur les
investissements je vais vous donner deux
ou trois chiffres qui concernent le
groupe ares dian les investissements
cumulés que nous avons fait sur toute la
période de détention de nos entreprises
sont de l'ordre de 30% de la valeur
d'acquisition initial de l'entreprise
c'est donc un chiffre très significatif
et nous avons investi plus de 16
milliards d'euros dans des
investissements sur toutes les sociétés
du périmètre darmian infrastructures en
2010 depuis 2010 donc c'est des chiffres
qui sont considérables voilà et on a
même observé est calculé que il y avait
une accélération du rythme
d'investissement dans les portefeuilles
représentant les actifs que nous avons
donc acquis par rapport aux capacités
d'investissement sur lehman société qui
était préalablement détenues par des
actes
industriels donc je crois qu'il ne faut
pas disons croire que les financiers
n'investissent pas au contraire les
financiers disposent de capacités de
financement qui sont extrêmement
importantes aujourd'hui en particulier
dans nos secteurs du ce qu'on appelle du
non coté est donc tout c'est tout cet
investissement sont aisément finançable
par les sommes que nous le devons aux
prêts de tous les investisseurs voilà
donc je pense qu'il ne peut être rassuré
alors maintenant il ya eu deux fois la
question de la gestion publique
alors je vous dire moi je suis à mon âge
j'ai commencé avec trois groupes
d'assurances nationaliser de gamme des
agf élus ap je suis très à l'aise avec
la gestion publique
j'ai toute confiance dans la gestion
publique et donc il n'y a pas de sujet
pour nous sur la gestion publique où
c'est là où sur la reprise de certaines
gestions par par les collectivités
donc je n'argumente ray pas sur ce sujet
puisque j'ai vu des gestion publique
très bien fait j'ai vu des gestions
privées très bien fait et j'ai vu aussi
de gestion publique ou privée très mal
fait donc le mot public n'a pas
d'incidence je dirais sur la qualité de
la gestion
mon credo vous le savez c'est beaucoup
plus le credo sur les équipes de gestion
qui sont en charge des entreprises
quelles qu'elles soient
voilà je vais passer le voilà mathias
juste pour compléter ce que vient de
dire de dominique senequier
je crois que c'est pas il faut pas
opposer publics et privés je vous cite l
exemple nous aurons nous sommes
récemment été choisie par les
collectivités locales allemandes qui
sont actionnaires à 75% nous sommes
actionnaire à 25% donc c'est pas
forcément incompatibles je crois même
que c'est une voie d'avenir et de l'erp
en dominant c'est la même chose c'est
une société qui majoritairement détenue
par une collectivité locale
je crois qu'il faut pas forcément opposé
les deux et je crois que c'est quelque
chose qui va ce même se généralise et
qui va avoir de plus en plus de 2
2 comment dire de deux présences en fait
dans ce dans des infrastructures qui
sont considérés comme essentiels
en ce qui concerne le fonds gip et
encore une fois il faut savoir
aujourd'hui que 40% des capitaux de suez
sont investis aux états unis pourquoi
parce que vous savez qu'en france nous
avons un système de l'eau qui est
l'affermage et donc les investissements
et les investissements longs sont faits
sont faits par les collectivités locales
et donc les capitaux propres et une
partie de développement
et de la croissance de ceux de suez
passe par l'étranger parce que le marché
français est essentiellement soit en
affermage soit une tendance forte
je suis d'accord avec vous à la mise en
régie
c'est une tendance forte et est du coup
les sociétés d'eau se concentrent de
plus en plus dans des partenariats / 2 /
/ / 2 / l'ingénierie mais qui nécessite
évidemment - moins de capitaux donc il
est essentiel pour une entreprise qui a
une vocation internationale
parce que le le secteur de l'eau est
essentielle pour nous français mais il
est également dans les pays où nous
investissions il est aussi important
d'avoir des partenariats et d'avoir la
présence d'investisseurs des pays où lé
hulu la société souhaite se développer
selon qu'ils sont sexuelle le capital de
toutes façons resterait à majorité
français il faut le dire et même plus
français que maintenant puisqu'on a dit
le capital et avec beaucoup de sociétés
de gestion étrangères lorsque la société
est cotée en bourse soit là et il y
aurait aussi une part beaucoup plus
importante d'actionnariat salarié ce qui
est toujours extrait extrêmement
dynamique pour pour les entreprises j'ai
toute dernière question comme je voulais
dit monsieur frérot oppose maintenant
beaucoup le projet industriel français
contre un projet financier américain est
ce que vous considérez que le projet
suez 2030 est un projet industriel
certes oui certes une hésitation
[Musique]